I have studied business I'm something
I'm interested in it and it relates to
how we decorate Amendment part of what
we do is we decorate them in order to
make us feel a certain way in terms of
the pictures we put up the music we play
you know and how we arrange it you know
one of the things we found for example
is that is that and we know you know
extraversion is defined by bit people
who are sociable and outgoing and we
know those people they just like people
they did you know for them the thought
of going to party is exciting whereas
for an introvert it's it's it's just
fills you with anxiety the thought of
all those people and having to talk to
them so then in all kinds of context as
evidence for them like in people but but
they they craft environment to do that
so we found one of the things we found
was that extroverts had offices that
were thought to be inviting and so they
they just want people to come in they
just tempe they have you know whether
it's their cubicle or whatever it's just
it just it make it makes you want to go
and they maybe have a bowl of candy on
the desk of a comfortable chair and it
makes you want to go in a Linga
introverts don't they don't want you in
there they'll you know there's their
doors are more like to be closed and
they just don't so they are creating a
space to try and reflect and reinforce
this house now
you